okay so daniel rpk has just dropped a
big report about what's going to be
shown in hall hm marvel's comic-con
event there's been a lot of speculation
over the last couple of weeks with some
leaks hyping up the event quite a lot
they said things like the x-men and
fantastic four lineup were going to be
announced but since then there's been a
lot of talk about how people should
actually lower their expectations
according to numerous reports marvel
will actually be saving a lot of their
big announcements for d23 which is of
course a disney event this makes sense
as it's of course their own thing and it
would help them gain more attention on
the rest of the disney products rather
than giving attention to their
competitors now daniel has given us what
could likely be aligned with the things
that will be shown and though you should
take this with a pinch of salt he tends
to be bang on with trailer releases and
movie announcements according to his
patreon which also yeah go sign up to it
marvel will show footage for black
panther wakanda forever guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 and also she-hulk daniel
said there are some things up in the air
at the moment and potentially we might
get a first look at lucky season 2 along
with some things from echo we have had
some behind the scenes looks at loki and
therefore that would make a lot of sense
lastly he said that a few films will be
announced and though he wasn't told what
they are we can kind of speculate over
this the mutants was teased by deadline
and we could potentially even get the
mention of the fantastic four or maybe
even deadpool 3. anyway that's what to
expect going into the event but let us
know below what you want to see if
you're watching this on our main channel
then just to let you know we've launched
eclipse one two full of videos just like
this that'll be linked is the top
comment and we're almost at 1000
subscribers so please go check it out
for some heavy spoilers highlights if
you want to see a full breakdown of
every room in an upcoming marvel movie
then that will be linked on screen right
now by the way thanks for clicking the
video and i hope to see you next time
take care peace